Father's Day of course is Holly and Andy
I'm curious you have any plans you know
just go out to dinner so ah crap what
was that the hell was that oh that's
that's Tony one of our cameraman Tony
what's all crap well what's what's wrong
I forgot Father's Day was coming up and
that means I gotta call my dad okay well
you know you don't have a good
relationship with your dad man he's a
real old-fashioned guy and he always
makes it very clear that it doesn't
think I'm successful or smart or a real
man well that that's too bad isn't he
proud of the fact that you work on my
show now you know I tried to tell him
about that but he cut me off and he said
that show blows and then he went on for
like an hour with lots of reasons why
you made some pretty good points
actually you want to hear some no I
don't want to hear exactly why your dad
thinks this show blows so anyway I told
my dad that I was a heart surgeon and a
professional soccer player but you told
them you were both a heart surgeon and a
soccer player I told him I was both
things yeah okay okay what happens when
your dad visits he never visits he's too
busy traveling the world is the bassist
for Radiohead at least that's what he
tells me
okay well
it sounds like you and your dad have a
very weird relationship Tony
ah thanks Conan hey you know what
instead of waiting until Father's Day
what if I call my dad right now and you
guys can make it sound like I really am
a heart surgeon and a soccer star and
the audience can help too what do you
guys say huh should we all right I think
we should help Tony out with Father's
Day yes let's do it
that's great ok here's what we're gonna
do I'm gonna call my dad when you hear
me say hi dad Andy I want you to start
making a beeping noise like I'm in the
middle of a heart operation that Conan
when you hear me say how's the weather
you're gonna say doctor we're losing him
Andy that's when the beep flatlines beep
you know the drill then when I say
scalpel Conan you say in a sexy lady
nurse voice dr. your hands are too large
and masculine to hold the scalpel then
when I say when I say the other thing I
did with the stump will work Andy the
beeping becomes normal again and then
Conan you say you did it dr. Tony the
cameraman no wait wait wait wait wait
you said your dad doesn't know you're a
cameraman the cameraman is my last name
Conor are you serious yes it is
literally the weirdest coincidence ever
anyway there's a lot more so listen up
after I say I fixed this patient's heart
and I gotta go play soccer now Andy I
want you to take off your shoes and
whack them on Kona's desk so it sounds
like I'm running then when I say I'm in
the soccer stadium the audience all you
guys have to do is make that kind of
like kind of background noise right like
in a stadium then when I go hold on that
I got to kick the ball I want the whole
audience to cheer like their team just
scored a goal then Andy you say then
Conan you say and that's goal number
four for Tony the cameraman the best
soccer player in the world his father
must be so proud and now a word from our
sponsor but say all of that in Spanish
got it
no I'm not gonna say it not right great
then you also say back in your normal
voice
hello I'm telling O'Brien at my age I
mean all the help I can get both on TV
and in the bedroom that's why I use
maximum Tony cream the only male
performance enhancer you made entirely
from the sweat of the most masculine man
on earth
Tony the cameraman but also in Spanish
okay this is ridiculous just no way I'm
doing that all right we're ready okay
here we go
fine okay all right here we go hi dad
beep beep yeah beep how's the weather
doctor we're losing him hold on dad I'm
in the middle of a heart operation
scalpel okay the thing I pay with the
scalpel worked I fixed that patient's
heart and now I got to go play soccer
okay I'm running hey dad it's about to
get loud I'm in the soccer stadium
I'm gonna kick the ball mouth
[Applause]
eso es el goal numero Quatro peritoneal
confirm our dough el mejor foot Paulista
del mundo su padre tendrá que estar ogle
ASIMO de el y hora estas palabras de
nuestro Patras in adore
hola yo soy Conan O'Brien
amia dad yo necesito toda la ayuda
posible tanto en la televisión como en
el dormitorio por ESO euro so maximum
Tony cream el único supplemental Darrell
se para Voronezh enjoy birthday dance
alone el hombre mas mas platino de mundo
Tony tell Tamara groffo
[Applause]
it's fantastic good job Andy runner
that's amazing
so Tony did he buy it I got no idea went
straight to voicemail glad everybody all
right good night
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you